[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever oh it's off the cuff
dave let's go tim's trying to prove
himself so uh we got we got work we're
delirious you're here dog
all right people have been like yo man
why is it all
dicks now guess what cause we've been
[ __ ] going crazier with all dicks
especially on the patreon i said the
same thing when i came in though man i'm
like damn
another another [ __ ] fast
i love it i love this yeah i get it it's
the best time you can get away from her
wife too
yeah boys night talk about do you guys
feel like you need that like
guy time now like since um you know
everyone is pretty much
married or like you just you just have
your wife's energy right and then like
honestly no cause jill's kind of a man i
remember
i mean she was here two weeks ago and it
and she had the biggest dick in the room
yeah she does have a pretty big the
weightlifter girls uh
you know they they the stairways make
their clits bigger that's exactly well
that's what it is you ever see the china
doll video
no not a dollar just china oh they
called it shannon dolby
did they i think so oh i think it was
always been china yeah but yes we've
seen the video yeah the big old clip
it's quite
i need a break from chia but i do
definitely like because i i never go out
at all with anybody you know what i'm
saying so it's like so you bless us with
your present
so i mean so now it's like for me since
the baby's so
little and like i feel like i just need
to help you all the time since the
baby's only breastfeeding yeah
then i'm like if i'm not working
then it's no reason for me to go out you
feel me so with you guys i'm responsible
to be at home yeah so for you guys i'm
like
i'm working making a little bit of money
and i get to
chill and drink very little bit of money
it's okay any excuse i'll take
i have so great daniel anyone that comes
in here i just feel so grateful
the very you guys dedicate so many hours
to us
with the very [ __ ] little bit of
money we give you i don't pay anybody
that comes on my podcast so it's like
well that's different because they can
actually get clout on your podcast but
on jk news you know
that's a different story jk news bro
it's an institution dude
yeah man so i'm happy to be here come
take some shots with the homies
but it really just feels like we're
we're just chilling
yeah like like i do this without the
camera
it this gives us an ex excuse to just
get together and [ __ ] shoot the [ __ ]
yeah but i don't know like i yeah i
don't know what that feels like you know
to be like
i need guide time i think i get too much
guide time i need some female time i got
too much hand time sometimes you know
yeah hang time man that too
you feel that you can't wait for my wife
or not nah well
it's nice to have the contrast of having
just hanging out with talking
about like you know interior design all
the time that's all she wants to talk
about
girl stuff you know you mean my wife
poker it's like punk or poke poker i'm
like
really she's obsessed with poker how
annoying this is the worst
like she loves games and sex and i'm
like gosh
wait is this like oh yeah all i want to
do is suck your [ __ ] and i'm like oh
my gosh
here we go again actually she's like
dude you know when i'm like sucking your
[ __ ] it's like when i'm playing texas
hold him and there's like you know
you hate the analogies you know yeah
it's stupid wait is this a new thing
like did she just start
yeah no she's trying to suck my dick all
the time no no
that's so you actually got her into a
book you got her book called the
mental game of poker game poker no she's
already been to
no she's been into poker but then joe
recommended this to her because joe
everyone knows po
poker d jens like should go to joe to
talk about like what's wrong in their
lives
although it's been so long now that like
i don't even
i'm not you were in the world big time
oh yeah yeah yeah like so you have a
deep knowledge of poker
that she is um she's just been
understanding
yeah and when we had a poker chat i
recommended a book for her she bought it
immediately yeah she's read the whole
thing already and she's applying that
[ __ ] that's how crazy she is like it's
that's awesome she's the best dude but
yeah no so she's obsessed with poker
right she's trying to play any real life
tournaments
so we're gonna play this weekend we're
going to go to the to the commerce
oh that's a good place to go you told me
that commerce casino my mom used to work
there
my dad used to work there what for real
i wanted to know each other that's crazy
yeah my mom used to cook in a thai food
restaurant at the commerce casino oh my
dad was a dealer
wow that's crazy oh imagination went
somewhere else but we're not we don't
have to talk about it no they use
our parents you somehow our parents use
survivors
[Applause]
congrats guys that's real cool man all
of our parents used to play at the
casino how about that you know
you're gonna play in the tournament too
[ __ ] no i wanna watch her but
it's fun because i actually so because
nikki got eric really obsessed with
poker it's
dude i didn't understand that poker is
like mafia it is
i had no idea i didn't know the depth of
the game it's like mafia but you're
betting on your moves
right so i started watching this cat and
his name's brad owen
and he's a youtuber who just he's like
shows up
to a poker game like in a casino with
like a [ __ ]
like camera and he films all of his
moves and he
actually narrates his movies wow so i've
learned so much about poker just
watching this cat and then also talking
to nikki pepper that's interesting so
i'm just very interested in it already
are you legally allowed to film your
games dude apparently you can
you could probably show your own hand
what's going on well casino
has their own rules i don't think it's
illegal technically
um maybe it depends on the state because
in
las vegas they don't allow a lot of
technology like
phones and certain things like on the
table but i don't think it's a
illegal activity and poker rooms have a
completely different set of rules than
the casino floor
because the casino floor since you're
trying to win money against the casino
it's different it's like absolutely no
phones allowed but in a poker room
you're trying to win money from each
other
so i've seen people like like on an ipad
like watch sit up watching a movie
playing
really crazy you know just collecting
the commission you know interesting so
like you're
i'm trying to win money from nick nick
trying to win money for me so because
the rules are way different they have
usb chargers underneath
it's like way different and the movies
like how to count cards
right but that's what so that's what i
found so fascinating about it is like i
love mafia already
thanks to all you guys right like i got
into mafia and then
i was like well [ __ ] you guys kill me so
fast to mafia why don't i play a
like a different mafia game so i can
actually play mafia because you guys
kill me so quickly in mafia
you know poker got me better at mafia
really yeah that's the real goal well
it's like that's i mean like okay so
you know the role of mafia right you
know the nerves that you have and all
that
right so like when you're bluffing in
poker there's
situations in poker where you're
basically gambling and
expecting like your car to hit let's say
you know you're trying to get like a
full house or something and you're
waiting for that last card because yes
you have two pairs
and it doesn't hit you're not gonna
you're not gonna freak out at that
moment and go ah i don't have it i don't
[ __ ] have it right yeah you're gonna
be like
oh i wanted that [ __ ] card yeah and
you go all in baby
and that's when you're mafia and you're
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] my
ass so confident right and then the
other player
they might have something that actually
beats you they might have a straight or
whatever
and then but they're like [ __ ] does he
have the full house [ __ ]
that's what they're thinking right and
you want to sweat them and bully them
and hopefully they're not strong because
if they do have the straight and then
they can test you they'll be like well
[ __ ] is it worth it
all right [ __ ] this let's go all in two
and you're like [ __ ]
you copy some people will test you too
they're playing with their chips
and then you know technically the move
isn't final until you let go
so they'll just push it forward and
they're watching with their side eye if
they hear you go
they're like oh this will has a sign of
relief he doesn't have you can't do that
in a lot of
you know the the rules have changed and
a lot of casinos since we
were oh really yeah last time i played
at the aria man we can't talk [ __ ]
anymore
what no dude that's like some of that's
some of the
greatest gate what would you say you'll
be like oh you have it do you have it
uh how can i say like hey michael choose
being [ __ ] suspect right now
dude in some in some poker rooms
there's new rules now and that was like
the whole game right it's like
yeah you just look at them you're like
man come on tell me and then you start
talking [ __ ] to them they're like you're
[ __ ]
full of [ __ ] whatever right now you
can't do it it's like when you're in
game you're just like you can't ask them
questions you can't say anything
like just some i guess some casinos so
like a lot has changed
and i think the game play yeah yeah yeah
yeah how many fist fights or whatever
go down you know like i guess that makes
hello sense for you yeah
that makes sense this is a brilliant
idea but i'm still such a noob that when
i see a
like a hand or whatever i i always don't
know if i won yet
until people tell me i'm always like is
that a full house
yeah you asked the dealer what happened
let me ask y'all this when you're
playing uno
you put down a draw how do you ask how
you guys play draw four
if someone puts down a draw four and
then you put down a draw two on top of
that
does that person draw six better you
guys play like that [ __ ] better than
leaving my house
every time i mean they didn't draw a
four when you put down the drop
or like it reverses back to them so do
you make do you make do
do you okay so select i play a card at a
time so if he puts draw four i gotta
take four
before and then and then we put draw two
and then that person puts draw two right
okay okay okay i mean if you put a
reverse then that means he
draws four we're not talking about
reverses right now okay let's say i gave
steve a draw for not me please no let's
say i gave you a draw
for come on and then and then steve was
like okay i'm gonna put down a draw four
on top of that
do you make steve draw the four or does
the next person draw eight without
anything happening to steve
he draws four he draws four that's how i
play hello everybody today's video is
brought to you by
babble are you traveling this summer
because a lot of things are opening up
a lot of people have been they were like
i want to go out i want to go travel and
and see the world and learn new
languages and guess what
that's what babel is good for because it
is the number one
selling language learning app and i love
it
because all the lessons are only 15
minutes long so you can fit it
in almost any part of your day and
what's awesome about this
is they use real world practical
language use so it's like hey where is
the bathroom they're not going to teach
you like will you
build a spaceship for me they're going
to teach you things that you're going to
use
how much is the hamburger stuff like
that
yeah not hey where's
my mom we never we never need that no
you never need
to worry about me you always she won't
be traveling with you this summer
because you are gonna have a hot boy hot
girl summer
yeah so yeah if you're trying to learn
language from real language experts
things that are gonna
an app that's gonna help you with your
enunciation go to babble.com because
right now
if you sign up for three months you get
the next three months for free and
that's six months
total for the price of three months
b-a-b-b-e-l.com with the code
off the record don't forget to use that
code to get the special deal
babel b-a-b-b-e-l dot com with the code
off the record i try to learn german
and i'm still trying to learn and then
the next person the next person draw
four draw eight
four oh okay okay heart at a time
interesting that makes sense
that's how you play uno it's uno well i
mean
when i was growing up and this is always
debated it's like some people be like if
you double up this [ __ ] has to
draw four so we will get to like this
one
oh yeah draw 10 [ __ ] because it was
like a two one two one two one two and
then
that's fine as [ __ ] there's no cards
it's like beer pong at the end of the
day uno are just cards you make up the
[ __ ] rules
that's like playing checkers when you
get to the other side you go king me and
also
this [ __ ] is double triple stack
that you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want
it's just [ __ ] going around killing
everybody i don't think uno corporate
would approve of what you just said at
all
dude we used to have poker games in here
oh
we would have like two three tables rap
and i remember like it was like
we invited youtubers viners everybody
like everyone was in here
like illegal gambling yes one table over
there
like a tournament y'all you bought it we
paid like 20 bucks but that was a lot of
money for all of you know us
starting off as being a youtuber for the
vine so they weren't sweating anything
they were actually much more broke yeah
that's true yeah i mean definitely now
oh yeah i think match was probably the
only one getting paid at the time i
don't know
but yeah all of us were playing those
were some fun times man like
we would we would treat it like a real
world series of poker
interesting poker squad let's go nikki's
in yeah nicki wants a poker squad nikki
wants
we used to have one hard the tournament
you guys are playing is it one you you
like you buy into
like you have well i i assume so i have
no clue okay
no it's not supposed to retirement here
jk pogba term yeah
100 buy-in i'm down a lot of poker on my
phone so i mean i'm down
guys let's do it yeah sure let's go test
our friendship you know what i mean
watch tournaments on tv i do need to
clean it up
you know i my poker crew it got
dismantled because one of the members
stole a [ __ ] ton of money from one of
our friends
and i'm and you know he has such a
degenerate
good vibe heart he was like
he had access to the bank account right
because he was doing business with him
and he goes i'm on a hot streak oh no
and you know what this [ __ ] i already
know what he did
he put 50 grand and i i thought he was
just
wealthy he's the coolest guy too though
he was i wish he didn't do something so
stupid right me too i really love
my eyes i saw this man win 80 grand
in the matter of an hour over a weekend
i seen him win
a hundred grand i thought this man was
extremely
wealthy right and then
i found out that he wiped up wiped out
my friends businesses
right and then i was like wait how's
that even possible because i was like
they only had about 40 50 grand in the
in the bank account i've seen this man
win hundreds of thousands and i'm like
what was this whole motive and he and
then he was like i was on a hot streak
you know
i just wanted to surprise everyone and
then like one day they open up the bank
account and it has like
way more and i'm like when were you
gonna stop
and that's a true degen you just don't
you're on the streak right and you're
winning
a hundred two hundred three half a
million whatever right and then it goes
down to zero i could win it back
and it goes to now he's borrowing money
from whoever
who knows what sucking [ __ ]
in the alleyway it's just it ruined our
groups
it ruined everything because after that
we can't it just
tainted it you know yeah for sure yeah
no poker tournament guys
mahjong we're playing modules let's
stick to crypto over here guys
where we lose millions look i have a
friend who lost seven figures
no but he's back he's back
which one is the question back isn't
like even or he's like up
no he's back get this i titled one of my
videos i lost millions right i'm just i
was just [ __ ] around it was a live
stream i did
and my mom called me the next day
worried
and this [ __ ] was like so during the
pandemic
you know i haven't traveled and um i
saved you know a couple thousand dollars
oh you need it i'm like that ain't gonna
pay
for one month's worth of [ __ ] i don't
need you mom i said seven figures of
debt
you stupid [ __ ] and she deserved that
she's and then he's like
but transfer it over the pause was great
the pod the pause was everything
this girl tried to send me money dude
it is man she's like well if you ever
need it you know
i'm still your mother and i got your
back i have 200 ethereum i just never
told you
i've been holding on to this if like one
day
i you know imagine if your parents just
like one day it's like
you know you're like crying and [ __ ] and
then like the lawyer goes
so they left you something and then and
it's like
50 bitcoin i would
what the [ __ ] i'll be
i'll blow my mind dude imagine being my
kids
and getting the will and getting no
crypto at all and you're like
what the [ __ ] but the branding was all
about crypt but they're gonna call him
in hot tub hey there you know yeah
it's broken
anything after that though good are you
guys gonna leave anything for your kids
who are you guys gonna leave seriously
honey [ __ ]
kids no like no you're like you're yeah
like you're gonna you're gonna
let them inherit your wealth i mean i'm
on my first i just started man
you're not thinking about the future
like that i am i'm thinking about future
child abuse already
[ __ ] nice you gotta hold it over their
head you know while they're going up
what are you thinking about how i'm
gonna [ __ ] them up
yeah because they're gonna mess up
they're my kids they better yeah
yeah if anything i'm just you know i'm
uh you know i'm just thinking about like
what kind of chores i'm gonna make her
do and [ __ ] that's the extent that's
that's that's as far as out as i've
thought yeah i think you're not thinking
about this
grand old house will be hers one day no
really no you think about getting a new
house yeah what's in your house
i mean like whatever new house you get
we got we got a little retirement plan
and [ __ ] i'm sure i'll leave some of
that too i mean hello
[Laughter]
i'm figuring out a dog she's barely four
months chill out geez get off my back
yeah i guess it is in the
chore starting to get chore capable and
i'm like
this is why you have kids because like
you'll be like oh i'm thirsty
i'm like give this to mom
and then i see it traveling across the
room
spill and i'm like oh my god this is why
people have kids they can do all kinds
of [ __ ] for me he's like geo let's make
five
more yeah the other parts that's how far
the raising port is the tough part
they have free labor huh yeah that's why
they popped out so many for the farm
that's why all the asians make hella
kids
i didn't know that i thought they're
just horny and then eventually the kids
start raising the other kids
have you seen that [ __ ] like the setup
all these pictures of my grandma's [ __ ]
they're like
toddlers holding a [ __ ] baby and the
mom is just chilling
yeah yeah that's the american dream well
that's why the whites
that's why the whites have a lot of
babies too so we wonder why
we different religions and have backing
for them the lights
that's what we do that's what we do
cultural thing we're raised to do it
make different kinds of casseroles well
diff no we'll know
mostly well that comes yeah at the
potluck but we're talking about the
religious practices of it
you can found a religion oh and then you
already have a built-in little backing
if you have enough
like kids or like donations see
your whole church is your family that's
the plan it starts that way hopefully it
snowballs after that some people crash
out some people don't make it
some people marry within the family and
make more family you know what i'm
saying
that's pretty cool so they turn blue
yeah every every now and again there's
like a phoenix that rises it's called
the mormon church yeah
and we're all like hey you guys did it
right yeah
i mean that's the true definition of
building your audience that's it
you totally built it the original
influences you made your audience
literally influencers yeah [ __ ]
dude you could have an american flag
waving in the wind
and no white's going to stand up and put
their hand on their heart like they will
stand in front of a mormon church
[Laughter]
every time i would have to say the
mormon church though
it's not even over your heart it's so
big they're flying
this is why cheers i pledge allegiance
to
you you've never been to mormon church
if you knew then you would then you
don't know why it's up here of course
i've never been to mormon church what
the [ __ ]
i want to go inside one they look crazy
epic at night
i don't know why but they [ __ ] they
shine that [ __ ] up
they do and that day they look pretty
sick too
but mostly at night
have you guys seen the book of mormon no
i haven't i'm so jealous oh
dog it's good those guys are my heroes
it's so great yeah spoiler devil scene
was crazy oh that [ __ ] was crazy
if you i'll tell you this i was watching
the book of mormon
and like you know and i love south park
you know because it's from the creators
of south park and i was in there
like with me and the homies and we were
like oh my god
like some of the songs i was like oh i
can't believe they just did that
and we're next this little old white
couple that's like you know used to
going to watch broadway plays and stuff
and me and the homies are cracking up
and she's like and we could just hear
them like next was
oh my god just disbelief at what was
going on
so that's her cultural reaction to him
and what you're doing is you're mocking
her cultural reaction
yeah to this i mean i apologize thank
you but is this health park her culture
from the south i don't that's hard
that's hard wow just blew your mind
that's fine that's true wokeness right
now
i think 7-elevens was their culture but
then i went to a lot of southeast
southeast asian countries and i was like
there's a lot of 7-elevens what's going
on
might be our thing let's be real
7-eleven is our culture
what is our i don't know
[Music]